45 days streets of namur in belgium are
colorful pageant of hundreds of
languages folk costumes and nations
participants for more than 250 regions
from all over europe are here in every
variety of dress but does cultivating
old traditions still make sense in
today's world it rock to see collegiate
folk costumes are something very
traditional of course but they continue
to develop we have typical old costumes
here but we now also have groups that
design their own folk costumes that's
why number of Celtic folklore groups are
on hand and no more this time Irish
dance has developed from a regional
tradition into a world famous brand with
an international fan base folk customs
unites people across regional boundaries
and folk costumes help people feel at
home in a Europe that's increasingly
globalized the people in these costumes
come from Greenland their traditional
costumes offer a sense of identity and
are passed on from one generation to the
next my mom and my aunt make it a to my
confirmation now I was 13 years and I
say yes to God in church many of the
costumes are works of art in their own
right the diversity of German folk
costumes has been documented in a book
by Gallego hohenberg of Berlin he
traveled around the country for five
years meeting with folklore groups
skip the intro folk costumes contain
hidden codes a kind of nonverbal
communication the colors the position of
the stars and the head expresses whether
you're a remarkable age what phase of
mourning are in and whether you're still
a child a lot was communicated in this
way today people communicate these
things with Instagram and Facebook what
if back then it was traditional dress on
facebook mohan babu and it often
Alzheimer's can I go hornburg subjects
pose almost like fashion models these
hand-tailored works of art can cost as
much as thirty thousand euros like this
wedding costume from Lower Saxony
mandora dainty condos with this costume
you think she came from the plateaus of
East Asia it's covered with golden boy
died glass beads fantastic patterns and
gloves perfect like water catcher from
Paris perfect as with me or co2 and
Oscar these ctrs designers have often
created new versions of the dirndl dress
which by the way was always a mixture of
folk elements and contemporary fashion
but there are no dirndl is like this at
the Europa
I think that it's very important to
preserve our culture so if we go and do
these things we maybe we lost our
culture or something this is holly but
it's overwhelming so many people in one
place all dancing their own dances with
such beautiful folk costumes it's
wonderful there's no language barrier to
dance and music this year's Europe ADA
is again a celebration of all the color
and vibrancy that Europe's folk costumes
have to offer they'll all gather again
next year with turku finland as host